An investment firm
creates a graph
showing the performance of a
specific stock over 12 months.
Over the course of
the year, is the price
of the stock rising,
falling, or staying the same?
So over this axis right over
here, the horizontal axis,
they have month by month.
And we move forward in time--
July, August, September,
October.
And in this axis, the vertical
axis, we have the price.
So, for example, in July
the price of this stock
was a little over $10.
Then in August, it moved up
to-- it looks like around $11.
And then we could keep
going month by month.
And this type of
graph right over here
is called a line
graph because you
have the data points
for each month.
And then we connected
them with a line.
And the reason why we
connect them with a line
is to really see if there's
some kind of a trend
here to really show that
you have something that's
moving from one
price to another.
And so line graphs
tend to be used
when you have something
that's changing over time.
Now, with that out of
the way, let's actually
answer their question.
Over the course of
the year, is the price
of the stock rising,
falling, or staying the same?
So on a month-to-month
basis, you have, for example,
from July to August,
the price went up.
Then from August to September,
the price went down.
Then it went up for two months.
Then it went down for a month.
Then it went up for
a couple more months.
Then it went really up
from February to March,
went all the way
up to almost $17.
Then it went down again.
And then it kept going up again.
But they're asking us not
did it go up every month.
They're saying over
the course of the year
is the price of the
stock rising, falling,
or staying the same?
And if you go from July, which
is where our data starts right
over here, our price
was around $10.
And even though there were a
few months where it went down,
the overall trend is that
the price is going up.
The overall trend is
that the price going up.
And you can even see that.
In July, it was $10.
And then by June
of the next year,
it was approaching--
I don't know,
it looks like it's
about a little
over $16, maybe almost $17.
So it actually
had gone up a lot.
They don't give us
July of the next year.
But the overall
trend is definitely
the upwards direction
right over here.
And you can see it just visually
by looking at this line graph.
Even though there's a
few bumps that go down,
the overall direction is upward.